[Musique]
bonsoir pause
pour
l'onu est bien agitée ce soir donne
envie de chanter patron je suis certain
que mes petits amis en ont aussi envie
lui s'ils veulent mon les châles
vélopop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
bonsoir
ali
baba il n'a pas l'air de bonne humeur ce
soir lors du show c'est parce qu'il doit
bientôt reparti mais je n'ai pas la
cacher ses bottes
cherche bien cornichons nous nous allons
chanter d'accord
hockey scotia
alouettes oui à lomé
[Musique]
alouette gentille alouette
alouette je te plumerai je te plumerai
le tout plus brûler
on le paie alouette
alouette gentille alouette
alouette est jusque là plus marrer
ouais t'es gentille alouette
alouette
jodhpur et si
je te plumerai
rebelles à la tête en hauteur
alouette gentille alouette
alouette je peux plus m'arrêter
on ne joue pas
chaque à peine à réaliser je te plumerai
d el al et elle
le met dans la tête alouette
[Musique]
alouette gentille alouette
alouette le château clairmarais
souhaitons y alouettes a de plus beau
chacun plumerai jeu
alors tu es content cornichons qui a
retrouvé ses bottes je les ai retrouvés
mais je ne suis pas content au
fait pourquoi elle n'est pas belle votre
chanson une alouette c'est un très joli
petit oiseau qui chante très bien et
quand on se promène dans la campagne
elle vient vous dire bonjour
alors faut pas lui faire de mal
et puis vous avez fait peur à juillet ta
mère c'est une chanson pour huit corps
du show même pour rire elle est pas
belle quand michon a raison oui on
lâchera plus et bien tant mieux bonne
nuit vient ma petite juliette à huawei
il l'a chanteront plus tu sais et bien
pas nui no more fun nuit
[Musique]
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors nounours vous avez bien chanter la
chanson de l'alouette patron mais je ne
la chanterais plus non c'est vrai je
n'ai pas gentil de faire mal aux animaux
tu as raison nounours bonne et des
enfants allez vite vous coucher est fait
pour eux
[Musique]
oh